hey uh so hi everyone uh thank you so
much for coming my name is mike tragalas
and today i'm gonna be introducing you
to something brand new call onyx and
talking about distributed workflows for
dynamic systems
so first of all who am i
i'm an independent consultant from the
seattle area i focused mainly on
functional programming closure and
building distributed systems if you'd
like to work with me definitely come
talk to me after i'd love to get in
touch with you
so onyx is something that i've been
working on for the last year of my
career independently
and
fundamentally what it is is a new kind
of distributed computation platform
and it focuses on providing an
information model to developers where
apis and dsls are currently dominating
i wanted to completely reimagine what
distributed applications could look like
and the result that i came up with is a
distinct inversion of control that
effectively moves power normally only
possessed by framework level constructs
directly into applications
as a result onyx is able to compete in
both a batch and a streaming space
it's also useful for doing data
ingestion and things like etl or storage
medium transfer
and its architecture is driven by the
fact that our data centers look quite
different than they did about 10 years
ago
so some of the goals i had in mind when
i started building this was
mostly started by my contention that
contemporary distributed computation
frameworks are monolithic and that with
some very careful cutting we can come
away with a solution
that is back to simple functions and
data structures and using those
materials we're able to build much
larger and more dynamic systems than we
can right now
environment wise i'm specifically
targeting closure in the jvm
i definitely don't need to tell this
room how awesome closure is but you're
going to find that
onyx's api is blossomed in such a way
that it's reflective of the decisions
that closure encourages you to make as
you get closer and closer to the
programming language
so as i alluded to onyx is both a batch
and a streaming hybrid and supports
transparent code reuse between these two
things
we see that people really like this with
things like apache spark and summing
bird and while it's really really hard
to actually do this well
it's totally worth it because it gives
you a whole different set of designs
that you can employ to defend
specifically against human fault
tolerance uh similar to the lambda
architecture
there are three things in the api that i
really wanted by time i was done
and the first is how we route data
around the cluster so where we
previously had a message acknowledgement
moving data from node to node
in onyx we have first class transactions
so that's that's the level of
abstraction that you're able to work
with as you're building your distributed
application
the extensibility api is quite powerful
and unique in that it employs multiple
levels of dispatch
per api endpoint and has priority
merging and in practice this allows
people with different concerns like
framework authors and plug-in authors
and application developers to all move
in different directions and not step on
each other's feet
and finally there is a set of api
specifically dedicated to side effects
and state
i have seen so many code bases ruined
over the years due to lack of attention
to this detail
if you guys all do closure i'm sure
everyone has a dynamic war story
that it just it gets nasty really fast
and so we head that off by just making
it part of what you do
so in this talk i'm going to discuss the
problem space that led me to build onyx
i'm going to talk about the underlying
information model and the apis that it
exposes talk a little bit about the
architecture and what a cloud deployment
deployment ends up looking like and then
i'll show some code in the repple to
show you what the development experience
looks like
if we look at what distributed
computation
in a very simple sense means for
application developers it's kind of
about
taking data in disparate uh storage
mediums as input running them through a
set of transformations in arbitration of
transformations and then just shoving
that data into a set of arbitrary output
storage mediums and granted that's a
very very simple description but at the
end of the day that's what we're kind of
trying to accomplish
and we do this really well at a petabyte
scale with techniques like mapreduce we
we totally have this down
but what we don't have down so well is
what happens when that directed acyclic
graph or workflow as i like to refer to
it
cannot be known at compile time it's
often not a static thing anymore uh i
see you know plenty of clients that uh
require a solution
where this this sort of workflow is
going to end up being built up by an end
user we we have end users building these
like hadoop jobs up through like
drop-down boxes and radio buttons on a
web application and then they need to be
transformed down into
a program that's going to run out on a
cluster and you can't know what these
things are going to look like at compile
time
and so we see everything getting farther
and farther away and this includes what
the specifications of our distributed
computations are going to look like
and that leads me to assert that these
specifications that what the computation
actually is and not how it's
accomplished has to have very four very
fundamental uh characteristics to handle
this growing gap better
and the first is that these
specifications need to be agnostic to
language it's like i said these things
need to be able to reach the browser
because typically across all different
kinds of domains we have
end users who are configuring what these
workflows are ultimately going to look
like
we need to be able to take these
specifications and put them on a wire
because presumably your web server is
not going to be on the same node
as one of your cluster members and and
by its distributed activity of course it
can't
they need to be temporally agnostic it's
also often not the case that we
immediately realize what this
computation is going to look like out on
the cluster we might put it on a durable
storage for a week or for a month and
then only only then realize what it
actually is
and finally they need to be tolerant to
machine generation and this is what rich
is always talking about when he says we
need to have good machine interfaces
we're building larger and larger stuff
now and our programs need to be better
to talking to other programs and not
humans first the human interface comes
on top of the machine interface
otherwise if you do it backwards it gets
really ugly
if we look at what kinds of modern
tooling we can we can pull out to deal
with these problems
the first one that i started dealing
with was cascading which is a java
mapreduce framework on top of hadoop and
cascading is kind of about having a
class per operation that you can do
instantiating these operations and then
chaining them together through the
constructors to form an implicit flow of
how your your data is running through
your system
and it works well enough lots of people
use cascading but if we look at the four
characteristics that i care about we
missed out on the first three clearly
this is java we're not transcending out
of the language
you're not going to take this code very
easily and put it on a wire without some
intermediate transformation
you're certainly not going to put this
in a database very easily
i will give you machine tolerance and
that maybe you can use some sort of a
builder pattern to to work up your
computation but it ends up not being
that pretty anyway and i don't
particularly mean to beat up on
cascading because you know like i said
it works well enough and we use it but
it was the first one that i used and i
realized that something was really
really wrong so i want to take a deeper
look at what this code is actually doing
and i don't mean the inputs and the
outputs to this this code i'm talking
about what it fundamentally concerns
itself with because that's how you end
up getting towards simpler solutions
so after a
long amount of analysis about
what this technique actually does i can
tell you that it's at least doing the
following
you're at least specifying the mechanics
of how your computation is going to be
carried out you're saying how you're
going to end up doing this out via your
your framework and that's fair enough
you're allowed to do that where it
starts to get sticky is that you're also
specifying the structure here like i
said the technique is to instantiate an
operation and then pass it down through
the constructors of its subsequent
objects in your program and when you
combine these two things together
that's where it starts to go awry
but it kind of keeps going in that
configuration also takes place in the
same same paradigm
and and there's nothing wrong with
trying to
configure the smaller components of what
you're working with
but you end up binding the decision
of how you want to configure these
things all in the same timeline you're
going from top to bottom and all your
choices have to be along that same
timeline what we want to do is take
independent choices and put them on
independent timelines or better yet just
kick time out of the equation it's a
core tenant of functional programming
get time out of here and this does the
exact opposite
it's also the same thing with forcing
concrete classes
you're forced to give up your ability to
work in terms of interfaces because you
have to pick what concrete class is
going to underlie uh the the dependent
of what you're using and again it's
almost unfair in saying you have to pick
a concrete class of course but does it
have to be on the same timeline as
everything else is that convenient for
you
often for me it wasn't and it was it was
very frustrating
and by time you've built up this
computation by chaining everything
together what you get back is a black
box
this is a baked object that you're not
going to retroactively ask about its
composition and try to reason about what
you just you know built
unfortunately you can't even jump into
one of the middle of these things and
then change it and get a new workflow
it's not like persistent data structures
it's this mutable in place thing
and perhaps worst of all and certainly
most subtle of all for me i didn't get
this for at least nine months of using
this framework was that you're
implicitly accruing state with this kind
of technique and it's not even that like
you're you're uh in this example it's
reusing the same object and mutating it
in place you could use different objects
the the thing that burns is that you see
on line three towards the end of the new
regex filter you're assigning identity
to manners of expression
and if you think about it that's kind of
crazy because you're parameterizing this
thing with that regular expression and
suddenly you care about its identity and
when you have to care about identity
from a distance it hurts a great deal an
identity based approach is not the way
to handle a very dynamic system you need
a values based approach to be able to do
that and i think that we've kind of
become infatuated
with how short we can write these
programs right we're seeing like oh i
could do map redu or word count in like
five lines
and
we know that um
line length is is an empty promise in
terms of you know faster schedule
smaller budget et cetera et cetera um
and i think what we need to do is to
unify the power of functional
programming with the configuration
constructs necessary to tune high volume
fault tolerant applications
oh my wifi i might have gone out i was
about to open source it oh there we go
and you know
there we go
gonna have to change my password
okay
there it is
anyways uh
thank you
uh but my point while trying to do that
you know simultaneously it was real we
need to be able to bring what we have in
functional programming uh to the the
ability to be able to talk about the
fact that we are on a cluster and we do
need to tune these things we can't we
can't pretend like it doesn't exist
uh and so another thing that we might
look at is storm and i think that storm
gets gets quite closer
to to what we're looking for but it
still misses out a little bit we see the
use of closure data structures here with
the maps and the topology and the
keywords and it's getting better but you
still see these spout and bolt spec
functions or macros and at the end of
the day that ends up hurting your
ability to be able to talk more
generally and transcend at a closure so
this this also doesn't do it for me
finally you might pick up kaskalog
and what i'm going to say is at least
true caspalog 1 where the api was
predominantly macro based
when you use macros for an approach like
this
you give up all these characteristics
while there are a lot of great qualities
to macros runtime programmatic
generation is not one of them so again i
can't i can't do what i want to do with
this kind of system
so as i said the things that i've been
working with since i started getting
distributed systems are kind of
monolithic and that
with really careful thinking you can
come away with at least six orthogonal
things
and i'm gonna take you through how onyx
uses these six things in a very
straightforward example so we're gonna
pretend that we're ingesting some input
records of just two fields of name and
age and as output uh we're gonna
transform these things into just
uppercase names and ages uh and forgive
the simplicity so you could you could
pretend like we're doing this at like
terabyte or petabyte scale whatever
makes you feel like this is worthwhile
so the first thing that i want to talk
about that we pull out from from the mud
ball is is data representation
and what i mean is when i say how we
declare the names of values from a
function to another function because
presumably you're not going to be in the
same address space since you're out on a
cluster
and the typical way that we see this is
by representing it as tuples and fields
and these are ordered explicit sequences
of values so this is storm here towards
the bottom using its closure dsl we
declare the output field with a vector
and i hard coded the output tuple here
just for clarity
and you see that we use two vectors and
positionally line them up
so my problem here is twofold the first
is that we've introduced ordering where
ordering doesn't need to be since you
have those names and you can actually
see that alignment yourself there's no
reason to impose that incidental
complexity of ordering uh in that that
usage and the second is actually much
more deadly in terms of modifiability
because if you consider the fact if i
want to change name to first name
what does that mean for the
intermediaries for anyone who doesn't
care about that name but still needs to
pass it along
they all need to care and propagate that
change throughout the code right and
this is really really hard to change
your programs when you want to do that
and i think there's like there's an easy
way out and i don't understand why we
don't see this more
and it's just to use maps
in onyx these are called segments they
have a specific name for a reason but
i'm not playing a trick on you or
anything or introducing some more
abstraction it's actually just a closure
map there's no notion of ordering you
don't have to explicitly declare
anything since you can just associate
onto these things intermediaries don't
have to care and so we get back the two
things that were hurting me in the past
the next thing that i want to talk about
is functions and
i was almost embarrassed to write the
slides it's so darn simple uh
expression in onyx are plain closure
functions uh there are no macros there's
no state that needs to be around there's
no dynamic scoping as inputs they take a
single segment a map and they output a
segment or seek of segments and this is
the function that i want to run at scale
this is the materials that i need to
have in order to to work with really
dynamic and simple systems
i know you're all thinking it because we
were just there
can we use transducers and the answer is
yes
at least if you're willing to use an
edge build
if you configure configure
your application as such you can
indicate that you're having a function
that returns a transducer
and you can use that to process a
sequence of segments so now you can take
your
transducer use it on core collections
use it on corey sync then bring it over
to onyx unchanged and you're good to go
the next thing that we take out is
positional representation
and this is the really critical thing to
to pull out because it it's really hard
to see why it's there
and when i say positional representation
i'm talking about the order that data is
flowing through your system
pictorially our our example looks like
that i like to think of that as a
directed acyclic graph or particularly a
tree i think those
constructs are easy to reason about
where your data is actually going and i
like trees specifically because closure
has a good construct for that and that's
just a map because maps are actually
just trees you can have as many roots as
you want and they can they can branch
out arbitrarily wide and deep
and they are maps of keywords where the
keywords are corresponding one-to-one uh
to the nodes in the in the graph
uh it's a little bit more obvious if you
have a more branchy tree and again you
can just go as wide and deep as you want
and when you have this representation of
strict structure that's all it's saying
of what your computations how it's going
to flow
you get back all four of these
characteristics because maps transcend
language no problem
you can put them on a wire and a
database all day and they're great for
working with
other programs
now i have these three things i have
data representation i have functions
um
and i'm not tying all all these things
together and that that's where the job
of the catalog comes in and it's
strictly for conveying what the workflow
is actually you know trying to express
to actual functions down the stack and
this is easiest to see via an example so
if we have the workflow that we just
looked at here's what a corresponding
catalog is going to look like
it's a bigger data structure uh you know
don't don't be too scared though it's
like quite like an atomic schema
in that it has entries per
per uh task in the workflow and you can
see that uh each of these these uh tasks
are corresponding one to one here via
the the name key
though what i want to drill down on is
is the second one
which has an fn key
and that fn key is used for runtime
resolution of what your workflow is
actually going to be doing so
unsurprisingly that's going to point
towards a fully qualified namespace
function on your class path that's
presumably there at runtime and that's
just the function that we were working
with before we don't have to use any
kind of crazy macros to figure it out we
can just use resolve enclosure and when
you have those things
it's very easy to mentally complete the
circle for what's happening you take the
function and you reason about which one
it is through the catalog and then you
can mentally substitute it back into the
workflow and you have that ring going on
and
and this is kind of it i mean there's
there's boilerplate code to hook
everything together but as promised at
the end of the day the guts of your
program are going to be data structures
and functions and these are the
materials that i think are going to push
forward to building really much more
dynamic systems
notice that there's not even like an
onyx api call here going on
there's onyx slash keys or whatever but
you don't you know need to have it on
your your line again project to be able
to work with these just very basic
materials
so i think that's that's a good step
forward
but this is not a toy and i actually
built it to solve real problems so it's
extensibility model needs to let you go
further than that
and i'm talking about extensibility in
two notions the first of which i want to
override things that i don't like and
the second that's harder to capture is a
matter of composability and that's
augmenting things that are already
working for you but you want to come on
top of them and then change them a
little bit
specifically here i'm talking about
reaching new storage mediums
which is always kind of tricky for these
frameworks depending on how they're
they're working under the hood it's it's
not
it's not always the easiest thing to
actually do
and quite ambitiously i want to see if
we can do it with little or no code
change
to the actual application so in onyx we
have something called a plug-in which is
a method of adapting through the catalog
again an example is the easiest thing to
see
this is the same catalog that we looked
at before
and here's the same workflow that pairs
with it and we see here that the
identity up top on the first one is mem
slash read segments that's a plugin for
reading segments out of memories that
you can do development let's say it's
time to go to production and we're
actually going to be reading segments
out of kafka
the changes are quite small in fact
what you do is you you get rid of that
catalog entry and you know pretend it's
not there using sequence functions or
whatever have you and you you bring in a
new catalog entry um
and this one's parameterized for kafka
it's saying kafka topic here's my topic
here's my zookeeper and everything that
you need to know and this presumes that
you have the kafka plugin on your class
path already but now all you need to do
is reassociate that in keyword back to
this new catalog entry because they're
sharing that name
right
and and again this is kind of it because
we're able to push so much of this into
data structures that you don't need to
change very much else in your
application provided that the shape of
your segments keys
are going to actually look the same and
otherwise you're done and it's very
pleasant to work with these things
because you can go from proprietary
inputs mechanically over to in-memory uh
plug-ins so that you can diagnose
problems locally on your box with very
little changes to your application
just to show you how far you can take
this though i've been you know taking
common use cases and just like spinning
them on their heads because you have you
have this newfound coordination ability
to do things that were a little bit more
difficult before and this is kind of my
favorite example
so suppose you had atomic database and
you had five different peers running
five different queries this is the way
daytonic is advertised to work because
of the way that read and query scale
but you can also do something that we
don't talk about very much and there's
really no reason why you can't
take the same query and run it over five
different peers there's three things
that i can think of that are interesting
that are happening here
the first is that you can now take
result sets that couldn't fit in the
memory of a single pier and then
cast them across all these peers because
now you have the result set divided by
five if you're able to to divide up your
query that way
uh the second is that you're able to
stream your result set because now
they're coming back in uh in units of of
or rather five different uh units of the
query result you don't have to wait for
the whole thing to finish
and yeah so when you have those things
uh you're able to go a little bit in a
different direction
so if you think about how you can
actually do this it's not that hard you
don't need onyx to do it
you can reason that these peers are
actually querying the an index perhaps
the eavt raw datums index which has all
the datums in the database
we also know that this index is totally
ordered from zero to n
and since we know the number of peers
and we know the total number of datums
in the index what you can do is evenly
partition the index such that each peer
is now querying local to a specific
chunk of index and this minimizes the
surface area of the database that you're
now querying your query is going to
finish faster
and to be able to get a final answer you
just take the results and put them back
onto durable storage if your answer is
large enough that it wasn't going to fit
in the memory of a single pier to begin
with and like i said you can do this
it takes a fair bit of coordination to
to get right um but it's essentially
like doing a batch computation over your
atomic database uh so i wrote the atomic
plug-in for onyx to be able to ingest
and write data to and from daytonic
and and the same operation looks quite
like this your workflow is going to be
uh just as before you're going to
partition the index you're going to do a
broad read and read in all the datums in
parallel into onyx and you're going to
run your query and you're going to
persist all the results back together
and if you look at the two entries in
the catalog that i'm i'm interested in
which are uh partitioning the first part
uh you see that you parameterize it with
a db uri and a t value so that all nodes
in the in the cluster are actually
looking at the same database at a
particular instance of time and same
goes for the parallel read you can copy
these things out of
the the plugin and readme it's kind of
like chef in that you have the base and
then you parameterize the attributes in
such a way that's whatever works for you
and as the application developer what
you care about is this this query
function and that might resolve to
something like this you're going to get
a segment with key datums inside of it
and now all you need to do is run your
your your atomic query against this
datum's
persistent data structure because you
don't need the database around to do
that kind of query
the atomic queries work just as well
against persistent data structures as
they do databases
now you can't do all queries like this
but for certain queries that do need to
see all the data this is totally
feasible
and it's very interesting to do it this
way because there's so little code
actually required to get this thing
running right now
last thing i want to talk about is the
state api
and you know we've learned that programs
need to have side effects we're not
going to ignore it
we need database connections we need
file handles we need
connections to web sockets et cetera et
cetera and if you worked in a sufficient
sufficiently large cloud
code base excuse me
you'll find that using def and def wants
for top level side effects and state
management is a really bad idea
it gets out of hand quite quickly and
makes development uh very tough to move
forward
so in onyx we have something known as
life cycles which are managed uh ranges
of setup and teardown of state it's
somewhat similar to stuart sierra's
component framework though it goes in a
different direction but i do think that
things like a component which is like a
lightweight dependency injection
framework are a good idea for what we
have now because trying to manage this
yourself at the top level is totally not
the way to go
so there are five endpoints uh in the
state api and i care about the ones that
kind of pair together
so inject lifecycle and close lifecycle
are two endpoints that are invoked on
your behalf when a task hits a node in
your cluster so that's when you would
create something expensive like a sql
database connection and you can hang on
to that once and when the task is
finished on the node in your cluster you
can clean up after yourself
more granularly on a per transaction
basis
you're able to do something just before
you commit the transaction like log a
line or
submit some rep metrics to a monitoring
server and then after commit you can
again clean up so this is useful for
having that setup and tear down at known
points in time and you don't have to do
it at the top level
again easiest to see by example we have
a catalog entry it doesn't really matter
quite what it does what i'm interested
in is this custom parameter my param 42
and so you can use you can use these
multi methods
to dispatch yourself into them and we
notice that the identity is what
actually gets called there there are
four different ways to dispatch into the
the death method and we also see that it
returns a map and that's what that
priority merge thing that i was talking
about is all about you're able to take
these naps and then they're merged back
together in a particular priority so you
can override things that you didn't
really like or take something that
already happened and augment it even
further with like a decorator sort of
thing in mind
so we're able to get a hold of that
parameter now via the second argument in
that function
and that has lots of keys in it and you
can have full visibility into what's
going on
and via that map we return the next key
so if you want to do something after
every transaction you'd use close
temporal which again you have that key
that you created it's like a context map
you can now access down below and you
get you get this range of motion
throughout the transaction that's
running across your
your program and you have the ability to
do things at certain points in time
uh i wanted to talk about the
architecture quite quickly but it's
really not all that interesting because
how similar to storm it is to be honest
at the right we see a set of pure nodes
that do the heavy lifting and the actual
uh distributed activity
i took a very traditional play and i use
zookeeper somewhat because i'm afraid of
kyle
yeah
and that's just your normal setup we're
using that for coordination to the left
there's a single coordination node
that is you only have one of them it's
like hadoop's name node but it is made
fault tolerant through durable logging
and a heartbeat mechanism so if your
coordinator kicks the bucket you can
have a secondary coordinator standing by
ready to take back over
the interesting thing here is that i
chose hornet cue and specifically a
cluster of hornet cues
and i did that because i
when trying to pick a cueing mechanism
hornet q is standing out is quite
performant uh
i'm told through benchmarks i haven't
been able to reproduce quite these stats
yet that a well-tuned horn q cluster can
push into millions of messages per
second per node and that's the kind of
performance that i would like to hit
and you might say but wait
we tried cubase architectures in like
2004 and it sucked it was so slow and
that was true back then
but now network speeds are significantly
faster we have 10 gigabit plus switches
at commodity costs in our data centers
and
some great research out of berkeley
shows that disk locality inside your
data center doesn't matter anymore we
have that whole notion of move the code
to the data in hadoop because moving the
data would just have been a disaster
but don't impose that constraint on
yourself anymore you could have these
fast switches
and
and not care there are other problems to
worry about
okay so just a quick demo um
i want to show what the full example
looks like that we were running uh and
so this is this is the line again
project and it has a couple of
dependencies onyx itself uh quarry sync
and the atomic plug-in or rather the
core async plugin
so it's it's just a single file and i
wanted to show the whole thing beginning
to end
it's quite similar to how you run it
locally to how you run it in a cloud the
only thing you have to do is change the
mechanism by which you connect to the
coordinator
uh so you're going to evaluate your
namespace and that works fine i'll just
evaluate line by line in the ripple as
like go
the workflow looks exactly the same we
have that map via keyword input
through through the the transformation
and into the output
we also have the catalog and the thing
that's different about the catalog is
that we're now using coreysync for input
and output i actually ended up chucking
the idea of an in-memory plug-in via
for core async
there's really no reason to use atoms or
whatever to try and do this locally
corey sync works just as well
and you see that the identity here is
corey sync read from chan and similar
right from chan and these are straight
out of the plug-in for how you use it
so we valve that
uh and eval
uh the function that we've been working
with again it's a plane function there's
nothing surrounding it you get a map and
you return a map easy enough
the the key distinction here now is that
for onyx to understand where it's
getting its input from and how to write
it back out it needs to actually have a
reference to these channels
and so you use the state api to inject
these channels inside of it you might
notice that i'm defining these things at
the top level which is what i just said
not to do
for just convenience of demo i didn't
want to wrap them in anything else
so again we inject these in
we use an id to connect the coordinator
to its peers
onyx is different from hadoop and storm
and that it doesn't do jar deployment
for you
i think we've been doing that since 2004
and i i really don't think that's the
best way to go anymore we have tools
like chef and puffit and whatever and i
really i'm not convinced that we don't
have a better way to do these things
so while now is on the user to get your
jar across the cluster and use an
identifier to hook these two things up i
don't think we're going to fail at this
i think we're just going to find
something better
and as a result you can also have a
rolling restart because you can just
spin up your jar and use that identifier
to connect right out to the coordinator
you don't need to have uh the homogenous
jar across the cluster which isn't
always the convenient thing to do if
you're working in certain kinds of
systems
so now we have two sets of uh
options one for the the coordinator and
one for the peers like i said they use
hornet cue and zookeeper but you don't
need either of these things to start
developing because you can use in memory
modes for both of these so you can just
clone this repository and as long as you
have line again in java you're good to
go
i'll connect the coordinator to its
peers and it returns
uh and here's my my data
i have a set of maps here uh just as
before with some additional names and i
also have this keyword done here
uh let's see i'm doing on time this is
the mechanism by which uh batch in
streaming mode is switched between at
runtime it's a really simplistic thing
to do but it actually it works just fine
it just lets onyx know you're done with
your input stream it's effectively a
batch mode you can go and do something
else now
and that ends up working fine enough
so eval and put those onto the channel
calls the chan
uh start up the peers
submit the job
and then we're just going to collect the
results and then print them back out and
see that all the names are now upper
case and the of the age is recommended
by one it's a lot of boilerplate code
like i said and there's no reason why
you can't minimize this but this is you
know the full thing and you can just
shut everything down
uh you get a log here on the left it's
quite chatty and i plan to calm it down
once people start maybe adopting this
but going for maximum visibility you get
to see an awful lot of what's going on
okay uh i went faster than i thought it
would have that's actually all i had and
i just wanted to thank circle ci for
providing build resources
that was awesome and a consultancy
called infinite cloud for funding
performance testing that was super super
helpful
um so can i take any questions
i can't shake the thought that i just
exposed my password for github uh that
was running in my head the whole time
uh
i've certainly been hacked by now the
repository's gone um yeah okay
yeah
what sort of message reliability
guarantees and semantics does provide
like
ones at least once
it pushes all of that down to hornet cue
and from what i've discovered hornet
queue does at least once and that's how
it actually provides transactions
so i'm i'm leaning on that very very
hard so if you go and read how the
hornet cue documentation handles all
those things it's exactly that
um
uh sure so the question was uh so if you
have stateful data how do you partition
it so
can you say that one more time
now i was trying to repeat the question
for the yeah
so you have stapled it how do you
partition it for
how do you do like grouping and
aggregation
yeah you notice that in that
transformation uh catalog entry there
was a key that said transformer there's
also grouper and aggregator and those
are the only three things that i have
right now because i can't really think
of anything else that i want to add and
those have different semantics in that
if you return
just
anything you want from the grouping
function that's effectively how you end
up splitting on on that value and even
that shells out to hornet cube because
hornet cue provides those grouping
semantics
and then the aggregation nodes will just
be pinned with those same values every
single time
yeah uh so the question was what if you
have multiple input streams that want to
converge on the same transformer
what i plan to do soon is that uh be
able to have a set of keywords instead
of just a single keyword to support that
right now it's a little annoying and
that you have to duplicate your your
keyword across the tree uh but it also
works you know reasonably for now
okay uh sure if you wanted to do
something like a join uh say a window
joiner two strings would you need to do
the state bookkeeping for that yourself
yes so yeah if you wanted to do uh
joining two streams you'd have to
actually do this the coordination
yourself right now
okay i'm gonna go change my password uh
thank you guys